[Music]
in semen smuggler news hulu my favorite
submitted microsoft word is a metal bar
that's a funny nickname gotta face it
baby banger part ha ha ha
maybe in the life not his own of course
not at or the record we've never done
anything with oh yeah this is for new
viewers out there it's the inside joke
okay you will now be a part of if you
can store knit a column pedalboard Oh
little bit
I need to tell Val a bail oh no let's
not do that
Todd Police arrested a man smuggling
semen into Laos what little hotel
is it his semen so he busted nothing is
all in his Buttle i smuggle semen all
the time it failed men usually smuggle
it in the sack
you didn't keep there like a balloon
full of semen how much comedy have like
a [ __ ] gallon of calm like what's
going on here you have to keep it
chilled right because if you don't keep
it chill it's going to go bad it's gonna
fail why is it illegal to do it like
deliver come yeah where did he come in
AB aluminous follow the balloon Oh
what's wrong with you
that's how you usually smuggle [ __ ] I
give trying to smuggle a rock you either
put in a balloon to get over but all you
swallow those balloons total boobs back
up yeah what the hell is he why are you
trying to smuggle come okay so this
matters of rent come birdie at a custom
checkpoint comes comes boy could come
beat them did I say come son I did no he
did he was stopped at a checkpoint of
the Thai Lao friendship bridge but he
was crossing over walking when he was
thought over they noticed that he had
made a lot of frequent trips and though
they just thought that was very
suspicious
nobody business discouraged that much I
like meaning to cross between Thailand
they also noticed that every single time
he was crossing he would be carrying a
usually please okay
sweepy he'll be so creepy chair but that
makes sense it's like if you're here
like every week why the hell do you need
such a big [ __ ] suitcase
I don't know how frequent Olivia
something like that I know what it is
if I was gonna come Oh an animal come
that's what it is but I tell them is it
at a cooler so when they open the
suitcase
they found a tank of nitrogen appear
enter do it containing six miles of
human semen now you guys have all the
information so he says I come let me let
me ask you though why so important that
Connors so he was charged with violating
the law on medical breeding technology
so they have a law banning this which
prohibits the sale import or export of
cement eggs or embryos so this whole
thing is because of this surrogate band
that they have in Thailand I supposed to
order a Denver omelet
again are they not okay oh now why do
agen people need help in having babies
we have in babies too much it's not the
fact that they need help it's the fact
that they're banning foreigners from
hiring Thai women to become serious
they're not allowed but don't use our
people like their [ __ ] incubators you
saw that's what it is you [ __ ]
don't use our people for that because
it's already a gamble because you can't
even tell which was a guy or girl
nowadays so they're so beautiful looking
hi sometimes I didn't I'm just like I
don't know myself anymore
wasn't there lady of Thailand I'm sorry
I don't know the pageant name but it's
like the little AAA and you Miss
Universe or something like that but or
like it's like a beauty pageant
yeah and then it was like the most
beautiful girl in Thailand was born a
boy but it's actually a woman now yeah
and she's hot hot as hell and it's like
I don't care you're hot that's all that
matters you could be a [ __ ] giraffe
but if you're beautiful I got to give
that credit what it wouldn't freak you
out to be with a nope
nope okay alright I've already had this
conversation a million times man wait
good day do they have a penis right now
or no penis no penis no penis coming
that [ __ ] millions of times with no
condom that better is better okay Wow no
ovary no this girl that's been gaining
for about a couple years she's [ __ ]
perfect well actually not you guys
probably the [ __ ] like that but let's
see a few weeks she's [ __ ] perfect
and you find that hey I actually
transferred it over but I have a dick
but you need to wait a year for me to
get rid of it huh key wait wait would
you wait really this part of the Bourbon
you know be with it but he wouldn't wait
is that [ __ ] out yes you and your [ __ ]
ass has a bitchin swap on your stuffings
Batman oh you're probably just get ahead
or handle yeah you know me very well
because I get afraid if there's a penis
there oh there's a [ __ ] baby elephant
ah but as you're having sex what if the
penis wall does that does it I don't
know just pretty over hide it no no no
no no no no it's not about the sex it's
about the soul see it's the soul that
person that's what matters but then
would you jack your partner off no [ __ ]
no you I want you please your boy there
it's like saying this your partner has a
crazy [ __ ] rash would you lick the
[ __ ] out of it I don't know
you know why baby because they are born
in the wrong body it doesn't belong
that's not there it wasn't meant to be a
dick it's supposed to be a vagina right
so I'm not gonna suck that fake body
part yeah but but they still feel good
though they feel good they're stuff yeah
but you do realize I'm not ready for
that kind of [ __ ] yet okay yeah okay can
add the person's giving you head they're
boaters going to see that [ __ ] right
there so you have to be able to receive
it well I mean all right I take it back
I'm not ready for that kind of [ __ ] what
are you guys not on the whole band like
the fact that they don't let
Warners you know these people as
incubators because there's people like
supporters of this whole surrogacy thing
they're saying that it's a win-win with
the couples that are trying to get you
know their baby and then also for the
poor women that's a higher because then
they're getting money and they're able
to support their family then also
there's critics saying the fact that you
know this is reproductive prostitution
and child trafficking and so they're
saying that they don't want women to be
forced to become baby-making factories
just for them to support their family it
is it a difference and what we do in
America because yeah because they're so
[ __ ] poor is seen as a necessity
because there's all different girls that
are into you know sex slavery out there
and they're just you know I think this
is good for Thailand yeah it's good for
Thailand then I mean I think for them
it's in the best interest of the people
of their country to not be used as a
reproductive Factory and if that's how
I've seen it is done then yeah I think
it's great and I'm pretty sure for them
to the reason why they're doing that
because it's a cheaper alternative than
getting it done elsewhere mm-hmm so if
you're seen as a commodity and that's
how you're using human beings then I
completely understand it should be bad
yeah it's like a sweatshop for
baby-making yeah I am download that [ __ ]
because when I go to Thailand I want to
eat this really good thing to have it
the night side but nothing my factory
the night markets there it's kind of
like yeah like this this rice kind of
stuff but they wrap it in these little
triangle weave and [ __ ] and it's altered
and then they got like mango and sticky
rice and all that stuff I try to think
about hey which one of these girls are
[ __ ] baby factories I don't want to
think that hello my mother Joe Malians
please like the video and for more
beautiful videos look up there
[Music]